guys by now we don't have to tell you
2018 was a big deal for eSports we
watched in awe as some incredible feats
were achieved but it wasn't all trophy
lifts and highlight reels sometimes
things got a little awkward so sit back
and grab some popcorn as we take you on
a journey through the years biggest
fails disappointments and mishaps that
we're calling the top 10 blunders of
2018 kicking off our list at number 10
is a Rainbow six siege blunder for the
ages cloud 9 found themselves on the
right side of a 41 advantage during an
online match against a rogue and were in
full control of the game and that is
until they got just a little bit greedy
one toxic babe but he's a man on an
island he'll get it down on the mark and
there's still smoke there to possibly
stop a push but he's gonna get doubled
up on sloshed takes out Fox they pulls
out the shotgun they're gonna need to go
for a plant marks coming out he just
needs to solid hide but the time is in
there /you July to live cloud 9 what are
you doing
instead of just planting the defuser
while in full control loud 9 decided to
chase down that last frag and well it
went about as poorly as you would expect
that is a cloud 9 right there coming in
at number 9 is one of the biggest
blunders you can make in eSports
cheating and getting caught doing it and
it all went down during optic India's
match against revolution at extremes
land so they react accordingly for
safety we've all flash intubate he's
gonna get free Frank's crazy got fog and
Jason all clapping look at fault as well
great work from forsaken up a map after
taking the first 116 7 optic India's
momentum came to a crashing halt when
forsaken was caught by the tournament's
admin team using a file to cheat on land
at one point of time it was the
motivating for us also and this guy the
speak skills one peak skills one peak
skills one pick skills one four of us
are down back to the cz
from today onwards whoa I'm not trusting
anyone as you can imagine the eSports
interwebs exploded and forsaken csgo
career died shortly thereafter
but the means that came from the debacle
will live on
in it at number eight we've got cloud
nines junglers fence Karen who went a
little too deep in Lane at the 2018 a
league of Legends World Championship
cloud nine were battling fnatic in an
all Western semi-final to decide who
would get a shot at the summoner's come
welcome to champion select for the final
semi-final of world 2018 I am still free
clear with Kobe and officio fnatic vs.
cloud nine for the last spot in the
finals the biggest na burski you match
property of Alzheimer's Spence Garen
locked in xinjiang Game one to apply
some early jungle pressure against
fnatic
Viktor pick at least that was the plan
going in three kill yep you just watched
fence Karen promptly died to a couple of
turret shots without coming remotely
close to killing Victor in a world semi
finals game think he could just get the
kill ripple got the movement speed to
just run away from a height the same
Shou since Ghana's only level 4 right
now in the first gank
very unsuccessful at number 7 we've got
dota 2's beloved donger failing to
attend yet another international last
year after being invited to work as one
of TI sevens English analysts
admiralbulldog ended up being turned
away at the US border on account of not
having the appropriate work visa I
wonder how he actually got through at
ti3 how we go through border control
bulldog looks suspicious man he just
goes to border control and he has this
like goofy look on his face and he's
wearing his cap that he's worn and not
taken off for like four years
and he looks
[Music]
this year with Bulldogs appearance at t
i8 being all the more anticipated the
community was twice as disappointed when
it came to light that the swedish TI
winner had somehow managed to piss off
Canadian customs as well we've got
another special guest that we'd like to
bring out yeah ladies and gentlemen
welcome to late-game admiralbulldog
[Applause]
it remains to be seen whether Bulldog
will ever actually make it to a future
TI but going into 2019 the pressure is
definitely on
even Lord gaben himself seem to be
feeling the dollar's absence thanks for
your patience and getting to security we
may not be able to get admiralbulldog in
here but we got all of you
coming in at number six is a
heartbreaking moment from the London
major grand finals after a scrappy start
to the second half of the first map Navi
had a strong buy against a bare-bones
eco from a straw 'less going into round
19 it was their chance to take back the
map their chance to steady themselves
after a pretty shaky start to a major
grand final it wasn't too big it's a
quick fella that's it that's his
position to try to stop the pawn that's
all he has to do stop the blond
Edward Hicks in town eight seconds to
Pont the boy can they stop it five
seconds is up I'm gonna go down in time
I don't know if this time made upon the
bomb oh they took the lower bomb site
and incredibly be able to plant the bomb
before time ran out Australis would of
course go on to win the major but nabis
facepalm moment on the grandest stage of
them all will likely never be forgotten
[Applause]
number five we have one of the most
Awkward departures in eSports history
fly an S for left oh gee this year to
join Evil Geniuses
in the hopes of creating a super team
capable of winning at the international
but little did they know at the time
that was exactly what they were leaving
Lyoness for why did you leave oh gee the
team hasn't worked for a long time and I
can say personally that I lost all
motivation when the whole situation
arise where I could join eg I felt a new
surge of motivation where I felt like
this is really a team I can win with eg
and og faced off in TI's bracket stage
and og took down their former teammates
with the team that many predicted would
finish the tournament in last place
like on cassadee cursed ids back up to
the high ground curse my Manito comes
out the Damon Thompson TP inhabited by
the hang on
they'll take him into this Noble
[Applause]
oh gee with the fortitude to stick
through each evening it's such a
more exotic I mean you can feel it this
game there was the drama there was the
path of course OG went on to fulfill one
of the greatest Cinderella stories in ti
history and fly in s4 were nowhere to be
found
while they were hoisting the ages
[Applause]
coming in at number four we have this
year's most underachieving League of
Legends roster Kings own dragon X all
eyes are on King zone and their
star-studded lineup heading into the
2018 season as the League of Legends
super team were early favorites to win
the world championship during the lck
spring split they lived up to that
expectation by absolutely dominating the
competition but it was at that point
that everything crashed and burned they
lost in the finals of MSI to RNG then
chain that into an even more
disappointing lck summer performance
that ended with them missing out on
worlds entirely ouch Kings own dragon
axe the favorites the spring champions
will not go to Worlds for the first time
since 2012 coming in at number three
we've got dead Gaeseong qward joke at
this year's eSports Awards in an
ill-advised attempt to channel the 2017
Oscars at Deji tried to fake out the
crowd during the publisher of the Year
award and let's just say it probably
didn't work out the way he thought it
would
[Music]
everydays I'm joking I'm joking I
Williams is a jerk so Jane he gets the
blizzards
wordham blizzards listen
for those keeping track DG announced
epic games as the winner of the award
before delivering the ill-conceived
punchline he was joking about epic and
it was actually Blizzard who won the
award we're gonna have to go through
that one bit through it move on soldier
coming in at number 2 we have maybe the
most anticlimactic grand finals in evo
history
courtesy of smash 4 captain Zack and
Lima had been booed the entire
tournament for playing Bayonetta one of
the game's most hated characters so with
the target on their back they decided to
play off the fans hatred by stalling the
game with Bayonetta to give the crowd
even more time to boo and boy was it
cringy many controllers man this is not
what I was expecting at all
it's not what I was expecting at all
however they're testing
can we go up my commentary resilience it
got so bad that the tournament organizer
had to prompt the players to take
actions within the game to avoid
disqualification
yikes that kind of comes in layers I I
personally think that it wasn't very
wise to do that on an Evo stage because
everybody's just watching and then this
happened
topping our list is the embodiment of
underachievement in 2018 the Shanghai
dragons nobody more famously lost this
year and the Dragons who went oh and 40
during the inaugural season of the
overwatch league so this is my third
take on the Shanghai dragons and
everything I have said previously to be
nice this time unacceptable and to get
to the cafeteria dog Oh running late it
was not a good season they were on 40
they played batted and wing 140 not
ideal there's nothing there's not a lot
of good things to say through multiple
meta games and now maybe it after free
field falls once more Shanghai
failed to get a win in the overwatch
League Dallas comes out on top
roster moves a little in time and breaks
between stages to refresh in the opening
weeks of OWL I've had my suspicions
growing that for the Shanghai dragons
the league might actually be a
punishment from the ancient Greek
underworld they just couldn't even win
one single match sure they came close
doesn't cut it well guys that was our
list of the top ten blunders of 2018 I
hope you didn't cringe too much of
course the real blunder would be not
hitting the like button not subbing to
the channel and not commenting on this
video
so don't forget to do all three thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button
[Music]
you